every now and then sona and i will be
talking and there's a lot of joking
around back and forth but i sense that i
really got her mad and i don't even mean
to do it and last week i was talking to
sona
about my favorite pen now my favorite
pen
is and this is not an ad i'm not getting
paid it's the pilot
precise grip rolling ball black pen
i have them right here my blood is
boiling
and so so just before the pandemic hit
yeah i said to sona
and i i sent over the specs i know i did
and i think sona said
i think sona said i'm not sure i think
she was said like yeah yeah yeah the
same pen we always get i got it
so i think you fobbed it off on someone
the next thing i knew
uh you you remembered you handed me a
bag of pens this was
just before the pandemic hit and i put
them up in my a year ago
a year ago sorry a year one year ago
but there's a reason for this so then
the pandemic hits
and if for a while there's real lockdown
and we're there and i'm
and i run out of my trusty pens but i go
ah don't worry sona took good care of me
okay she got me just what i need they're
in that bag upstairs and i go upstairs
and i take them out and i start writing
on them
and it's a pilot precise grip
rolling ball fine oh god
not bold oh my god
yes and i knew that girly would take my
sight on this because you're a per
snickety you're just a snickety little
simon i know you are
and i about pens i doodle i draw i'm
constantly writing it has to be the
right pen
and i hate a fine point pen i hate a
fine
i hate a pen that's stingy with ink and
boy
that pilot pen was so stingy with things
the pen was looking up at me the pen was
looking up at me every time i went to
use it was going like
i'll never run out i'm inadequate but
i'll last forever
and and it would scritch script scritch
and it would scratch up the paper
and just scratch it up yeah spread
script scratch scritch
and i thought oh my god this pencil so i
open the next box same kind
same kind same kind the house was
flooded you cornered the market
on this shitty fine
fine miserly pen so miserly can i talk
now can i please
can i please talk and i was like what is
this hold on so then i go
on the internet and i decide i don't
have to
i must take action myself i must leave
my
oh god forbid you buy your own pens
do you realize how terrifying this is
for a celebrity you have no idea
sona this was a horrifying experience
for me i
opened my laptop by myself which i've
never done
and i went on this thing called amazon
and i
found what i wanted and they said do you
want it in
fine or would you like it in bold and i
said i'd like it in bold and they said
you can have as many as you want how
many do you want i'd like three boxes
please
it'll be there in five minutes bang
so all i did was come into work and go
see this pen sona
and i drew with it and i went it's so
much better than the pen you got me a
year ago
remember bold not fine
you blew a fuse oh my god
okay can i you blew a fuse i'm gonna
speak now first of all you're making it
seem as though you were like oh and i
just like i was like oh i wanted a bold
and you gave me fine
you texted me on a sunday in the middle
of the week
yeah and on a weekend and you started
basically being like uh i don't know who
got me
fine tip pen but i use bold
and i it was so long ago that we got you
these pens
and it wasn't right before the pandemic
it was like i want to say at least a
year and a half ago
and we gave you the pens and also
whose fault is it that you didn't look
at them to make sure that they were the
ones that you like
oh no no no you can't yeah yeah
it's your fault sir that you were sir
you tolerated the bad medical care
order order order you wanted bold you
should see if we're not you're bold
bro order i won't have this in my
courtroom go on sona
thank you matt matt was holding up his
pens
because just like you he has his own
pens
i'll use anything that writes but i'm
not a monster
i wouldn't expect anybody else to
recognize that
like the pen persnicketiness can i read
you the exchange
uh oh here we go how long this goes on
quick unimportant note i said
unimportant
yeah i just ordered more pens for myself
and remembered that the last big batch
that someone ordered was incorrect
i like pilot precise grip oh my
god the fact that you said it's
unimportant that makes it scarier
because you're not joking around
and you're very serious and then you
should see the size of this paragraph i
say
an important note and then the paragraph
looks like at least three sections of
the u.s constitution
i like precise grip bold and the last
batch was fine point
sounds irrelevant but it makes a big
difference so i've been giving them away
we won't need to get more for a long
time because i just ordered a lot but
given the pandemic and my mental state
this felt like a worthwhile use of my
time oh my god
oh my god i got that hold it hold it
then this is good listen up then someone
says okay
are you keeping the pens at home you're
going to bring them to the theater and i
said
i'm going to keep them at home and then
my next text says they're mine all mine
and uh then sona writes back yes they
are yours no one else's
then i sent her the link i sent her the
link
to the actual correct pen on amazon
and i write bold baby and then in all
caps
bold and then i say uh
then i blame it on some young people no
and then there's a part where i give it
to you like crushed it
don't forget that part because that's
what oh oh that's what hold up
listen to this so i go bold baby bold
and then i say this is the worst thing
to happen to anyone in the last year
persona oh god i bought you pens like
once a million years ago and i don't
think we got more this sounds like a
conan mistake if you're going to be lost
here
it's branded and then she said i know
you like playing the blame game but
maybe you bought the wrong ones off
amazon
maybe we look inward oh
yes maybe we look inward
says sona